summer vacations this year are going to
happen close to home for millions of
people
travel to the u.s is still restricted
international travel may
open up at some point but with so much
uncertainty it's hard to make any plans
that means foreign tourists are going to
be staying home too
tourism is a big economic driver in
canada
from accommodation to transportation 750
000 jobs depend directly on tourism
most of that economic activity is
generated domestically by canadians
traveling to places like parks
campgrounds cottages and
attractions across the country as
mitralay reports this could be the year
canadians
rediscover all the wonders of home
for kids it's the official sound of
summer that last bell of the school year
before camps and trips and while
at the very least no classes for a few
months first one's here
but the summer of 2020 looks more like
this
all our hopes and dreams dashed by an
empty parking lot
and a closed amusement park
[Music]
we're all griswalds now
inter-provincial travel is still banned
in most of atlantic canada and the
maritimes so only newfoundlanders are
enjoying the province's
famous iceberg watching season and it's
not even easy for locals
the iceberg tracker isn't updating the
location of the biggest birds this year
to avoid crowds forming
and across the gulf in pei anne of green
gables has been silenced for the first
time in
56 years atlantic canada's most famous
redhead
may not have covet 19 but fear of the
virus spreading
has shut down the charlottetown festival
so the bottom line is there's still a
lot of uncertainty leading into the
summer
each province has its own framework for
reopening but interpreting that
framework is up to the municipalities
and local health officials
and it doesn't always make sense so
tours and board officials are
recommending if you do travel
make it hyper local so first of all
you know we're really focused on staying
local
this summer um and um
if you're planning to go for you know
further afield then let's say
50 kilometers then call where you're
wanting to go and make sure that they
are
open welcome to the original haunted
walk of kingston
for the past 20 years haunted walks has
introduced the curious the darker and
ghostly sides
of ottawa toronto and kingston they
offer walking tours outside where health
officials say it's safer
which wasn't enough to sway toronto and
ottawa to allow them to reopen
only kingston has given them the green
light but they can't offer their regular
15 to 20 person tours
we can have social distancing between
the tour guide and between a small
group but i'm talking about a group of
no more than four people
so very small the impact on tourism
is going to be massive it's an 80
billion a year industry that contributes
2
to canada's gdp take away 30 billion of
that with no international visitors
and while the remaining 50 billion is
domestic
that assumes canadians will be traveling
from province to province
only nova scotia is open in atlantic
canada right now
provided visitors quarantined for 14
days the same rules that apply in
manitoba
quebec ontario saskatchewan alberta and
bc
are allowing visitors from other
provinces even though it's discouraged
tourism is big obvious is a big economic
driver
but it's also hurts the culture and
fabric of our community
in a way that i think is um you know is
going to be really difficult to replace
so what are families to do day camps
have been allowed to open in most
of the country albeit with tough
restrictions such as
limits on the number of campers and a
ban on transportation
which howie grossinger says applies to
80 percent of the kids at camp robin
hood
in markham ontario as a result
grossinger and his wife made the painful
decision
not to reopen until next summer the
outdoor experience the pool
the swimming the instruction and quite
frankly mike like
social distancing in the camp experience
are just not compatible
no you know you know we have
four-year-olds to six-year-olds a good
population of those
75 percent of my day camp population are
under the age of eight
it sounds bleak but travel agent
lorraine simpson says there
is some hope for adventure this summer
there are deals to be had
especially if you want to go to europe i
found some flights
under 500 to go to italy and also
portugal
and even greece there's some amazing
amazing prices
out there the hitch is that those
traveling abroad have to quarantine for
14 days upon returning
but that could change so you're rolling
the dice
flying within canada is an option too
and while there are incentives the deals
aren't as good
still simpson says people are itching to
get out of their homes
who would go with me on a very early
test pilot style trip
not knowing anything and i just was
inundated with people saying yeah i'm in
no questions asked yeah i'm in so people
are ready to travel
perhaps the most intriguing summer idea
involves camping but since most
campgrounds won't have bathroom and
showers open
tents aren't an option so that opens the
door and the highways
to rvs ninety percent of canada dreams
business in a normal year comes from
europe
but as we've come to know 2020 is
anything but normal
domestic sales are certainly up but
nowhere near high enough to make up for
the international loss
and there's a lot of noise being made
about rvs that a lot of people are
saying that rvs are sold out the
campsites are sold out it's lots of
nonsense you know none of us are sold
out so the rv door is one canadians
could walk through
if they're up for adventure that is